hey Vsauce Michael here the title of
this video is misspelled in honor of
mistakes mistakes are everywhere they
surround us like err to err is human
faults flaws faux pause fumbles and
fallacies are as much a part of who we
are today as the stuff we've gotten
right for instance if a knight knocked
your knuckle or knifed your knee why
would there be so many K's well the
Kay's are silent by mistake
the original Old English forms of these
words were pronounced with cuss sounds
tonight tonight Connie but that's a bit
of a mouthful to say and because reading
and writing weren't as common hundreds
of years ago people just pronounced
words the way they want to do regardless
of spelling spelling is fun Warren G
knows what I'm talking about in the
fourth verse of his what's next
he asks what's next what's next what's
an X et spelling isn't the only thing we
get wrong the history of science is a
graveyard of dead and abandoned ideas
fritz machlup coined the phrase
half-life of knowledge the amount of
time it takes for half of the knowledge
within a field to be superseded by new
better ideas or to simply be shown
untrue Donald Hebb famously estimated
that the half-life of knowledge in
psychology is just five years humans are
awesome don't get me wrong but we tend
to believe that what we currently think
we know about the universe is reasonably
correct even though statistics aren't on
our side previous generations
incorrectly thought the exact same thing
about what they used to think was true
my favorite examples of the ubiquity of
mistakes are production and
in popular songs they're like humbling
Easter eggs just waiting to be found for
instance Buffalo Springfield's for what
it's worth 26 seconds in the bee in the
lyric beware
is clipped as is the P in people at a
minute 24 once you hear the mistake
it's tough to unhear it in Hey Jude Paul
McCartney misses a chord and if you
listen closely you can clearly hear him
say in hell seriously it's in the actual
song go listen to it in fact there's an
entire website that chronicles mistakes
in Beatles songs take a look at this 700
year old prayer book a monk wrote it on
fresh clean paper I'm kidding of course
he scraped the ink off an older
manuscript cut the pages and rotated
them before writing all over them a
mistake well kind of recent
multispectral images of the prayer book
have revealed that the old manuscript he
erased was a previously unknown copy of
a work by Archimedes it was called the
method and laid out the heart of
calculus thousands of years before
newton and leibniz
if that one monk hadn't erased that one
book would we be hundreds thousands of
years mathematically and technologically
more advanced today than we currently
are it's hard to say all that is certain
is that we would continue to make
ridiculous mistakes like the Mars
climate orbiter this three hundred and
twenty seven point six million dollar
expedition burned up in the red planet's
atmosphere because when calculating
flight maneuvers NASA used the
agreed-upon metric units while Lockheed
Martin used the Imperial system this is
Neil Armstrong taking humankind's first
steps on the moon it's about the best
footage we have the original tapes
containing the highest quality recording
of that moment
have been lost they were probably
recorded over by later test missions ten
years ago Sergio Martinez became lost in
the woods while hunting outside of San
Diego hoping to attract the attention of
rescuers he lit a small fire but that
fire quickly got out of control and
became a giant cedar fire it destroyed
300,000 acres of land 2322 homes and
killed 15 people the man carrying a
wounded soldier in this painting based
on a photograph taken during world war 1
is henry tandey an english recipient of
the victoria cross four years after the
event in this image
Tandi caught a wounded german soldier in
his gun sights but rather than killed a
man Tandi took pity on his wounded state
and spared his life the German he
allowed to live was this man later the
man whose life he spared wore his
moustache shorter but still had the same
name Adolf Hitler in 1918 did henry
tandey miss a chance to kill hitler
detailed research has found that the
exact days their units were in the same
location don't quite match up the story
is apocryphal but what is known is that
hitler owned a copy of the painting of
tandy and in 1938 when meeting with
Neville Chamberlain Hitler pointed to
Tandy and told Chamberlain that man came
so close to killing me in 1918 that I
thought I should never see Germany again
so who's wrong maybe Hitler confirmed
the story merely because he hoped to
make up extra evidence that Providence
have kept him alive to pursue his goals
either way someone is mistaken missed
opportunities are a bummer obsessing
over them is not healthy but regret is a
powerful emotion
how do you deal with regret with guilt
can you in the early morning hours on a
bench outside a hotel in Anaheim this
summer they Frank told me something I am
going to paraphrase I love this metaphor
stuff in your past is like a carving on
the bark of a sapling over time the scar
the carving won't go away because of the
way trees grow it won't go up or down
much either it'll just stay right where
it began it might even get darker but it
won't get bigger you however can you can
keep growing doing more things more
branches being more things the wound
won't get smaller but you can make it a
smaller part of who you are
maybe regrets are like that they stick
around forever like arbor glyphs or
maybe they make like a tree and leaf a
red or purple leaf in the autumn as days
get shorter and chlorophyll production
decreases the yellow and orange
carotenoids which are always in leaves
appear as the green fades but red and
purple leaves are the interesting ones
as winter approaches it would seem to be
a good time for trees to conserve energy
but some trees do the opposite instead
of giving up
they spend extra energy producing
anthocyanins to turn their leaves red
and purple hues these colors protect
their leaves from sun damage before
their nutrients can all be used and may
also be a defense against insects
looking for a parasitic home a way for
the tree to tell the insects yes I am in
part dying but not without a fight I am
still very much vital drought and even
tourniquets applied by man can bring
about these colors prematurely when you
look at beautiful autumn colors you are
looking
stress but the bigger the fight the
trees put up the more energy they put
into their defenses at the very end the
more brilliant their colors will be
winter will eventually come but
scientifically the brightest deepest
most remarkable colors come from not
giving up too easily or quickly and as
always thanks for watching